[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the junior senator from New
Mexico asked the assistant director of
the FBI's counterintelligence division
to explain what the Intel services mean
when they describe someone as an
unwitting agent of a foreign power the
FBI man did so and then the junior
senator from New Mexico followed up
accordingly quote by effectively
reinforcing the Russian narrative and
publicly saying that our system is
rigged did then candidate Trump now
president Trump become what intelligence
officials call an unwitting agent the
FBI man waited fully seven seconds to
answer and while straining to make his
reply he inadvertently turned off one of
the microphones before him at the Senate
hearing finally bill pre-snap of the FBI
looked at senator Martin Heinrich and
said I can't really comment on that in a
democracy in a republic in a
constitutional monarchy even in an
autocracy or Kingdom or dictatorship in
any form of national government anywhere
that claims to be independent of foreign
control there is only one acceptable
answer to the question of whether a
former candidate for leadership now the
leader has become an agent unwitting or
otherwise of another country the only
acceptable answer is no any other answer
from any competent authority and the
calamity described by that answer is the
gravest that a nation can face being
taken over by another nation i sat at
this desk and warned as long ago as last
summer
that this was coming i sat at this desk
and insisted as long ago as last autumn
that this could be avoided i sat at this
desk and pleaded as long ago as last
Thanksgiving that this must be thwarted
i sat at this desk at the time the flynn
kiss lyac story was just a tinfoil hat
rumor and urged that this be
investigated I have sat at this desk for
130 commentaries and begged that this be
understood
what it is our willingness to abide the
control of this country by Donald Trump
and the mercenary gang with which he has
surrounded himself was and is and will
be in reality our willingness to abide
the control of this country by another
country we are at this moment in a
position akin to where our founding
fathers were literally under the control
of the leaders of a foreign power who
have placed at the head of the legal and
military forces of this continent a man
who is beholden not to us but to them
they the Russians may be ruling us their
satellite the province formerly known as
the United States of America my active
means we know little of but I do think
that is only a remote possibility and in
fact far more trouble than it would be
worth for them at suffice is to have a
man in charge who occasionally has a
clear thought in his head like how great
it was when the skies here were darkened
by the smoke from coal burning factories
or how great it was here when women had
no say in their own lives or how great
it was here when we didn't worry about
anybody else's health or anybody else's
safety or anybody else's education or
anybody else's survival it suffices to
have a man who will view international
diplomacy as a business negotiation in
which the threats and financial
blackmail he used in his business life
will also succeed when in fact they will
destroy the influence of this country
and enable the other nations of the
world to expand their power at the
expense of our ability to defend
ourselves in Russia it suffice is to
have a man to whom everything nation
loyalty freedom everything is secondary
to power and applause to the point where
he cannot conceive of even wondering
where the power comes from nor who it is
who is applauding in essence Trump asked
the FBI director to publicly clear him
of what becomes a
we evident with every passing week that
whether or not he was hands-on enough
were interested enough or sane enough to
understand it at the very least there
was to quote Trump himself Russian
meddling of election election meddling
by Russia the Russians were meddling
unquote the Russians were meddling to
get him elected now seeing only another
opportunity for applause he says it that
he is not mentally competent enough to
realize how this implicates him either
directly or simply as the head of the
campaign that benefited from the Russian
meddling his apparent inability to
understand what he says is irrelevant
asked the head of the FBI to publicly
clear him of the greatest crime in the
history of this country the one that
benefited him above all others here and
after the head of the FBI would not do
this he fired him and then it was
revealed he had asked the head of the
National Security Agency to publicly
clear him of the greatest crime in the
history of this country the one that
benefited him above all others here and
the head of the NSA would not do so and
then it was revealed he'd asked the
Director of National Intelligence to
publicly clear him of the greatest crime
in the history of this country the one
that benefited him above all others here
and the DNI would not do so and then a
Democratic senator asked the assistant
director of the FBI's
counterintelligence division it's number
two men on crimes by foreign countries
to clear Trump of the mildest least
egregious least responsible version of
the greatest crime in the history of
this country
the one that benefited Trump above all
others here and the FBI man would not do
so
none of them would clear him what other
conclusion are we to reach he says the
Russians meddled in the election he won
the election he is guilty in the best
kindest most generous most forgiving
interpretation of being to stew
or too crazy to realize that he could
have stopped them from taking over our
country the 4th of July is next week I
wonder if by then it will still mean
anything in this country resist peace